2015 what are some of the film or even
television shows that are out where
there's some very deeply wounded
fascinating people
okay best example true detective season
one and I think television by the way is
80% of our business now as story
consultants five years ago was 80%
movies why is TV become this explosive
Golden Age and it's because now there
are no constraints on what you can see
insects what you can say television has
no more rules so what you saw in a in a
story like true detective is what I call
going from saving a cat to killing the
cat because that's where we are now we
are we're constructing dark heroes that
people want to watch why do people want
to watch dark heroes because nobody's
all good and nobody's all bad and that's
part of why superhero movies are failing
because that's not us
we all know as people that we are not
only good we're also bad and so killing
the cat simply means showing us dark
heroes who are like us we can accept
that we couldn't 20 30 years ago
television was just about good people
and really bad people well now
television has become more like the
russian novel of the late 19th century
where Tolstoy was writing where people
aren't good or bad
everybody's a villain and everyone's a
hero so this dark hero is more like us
okay so in true detective first year we
had two heroes we had Matthew
McConaughey and we had Woody Harrelson
and these two guys were both deeply
wounded but one of them had taken their
wounds and decided that they were just
going to live in a happy place and the
other would had taken his wound which
was his child had been killed and he
decided the world was horrible and dark
and meaningless and so for an entire
year we watched these two guys bicker
and argue with each other and what the
argument was really about was you
the world a horrible meaningless place
or is it a place of just love and
happiness where we all can live and that
argument between those two guys was
really made up the interesting part of
this whole story because we all believed
really the worlds both that it's got
poison in it and it's also got good in
it but that's why this dark hero is
becoming what we all want to see
Breaking Bad the dark hero really The
Sopranos Mad Men these are all examples
of dark heroes and that's what
television is really full of right now
Wally and the beaver tonight would be
considered would it be Eddie Haskell
that we would want to watch what was
interesting about Wally and the beaver
was when it came out it was the first
television show to really show kids as
not just these perfect little perky kids
they actually argued with each other for
then that was they were dark heroes both
wiling the Beave because the other shows
were like daren't Donna Reed Joan said
kids were just automatons so story is
marching towards more and more realistic
ideas of what we are as human beings and
none of us are real heroes and none of
us are real villains we're all a mixture
but the core wounds and true detective
were about thinking that the world is an
awful place because Matthew
McConaughey's character lost his kid and
Woody Harrelson's character didn't
didn't feel loveable so he put on a
happy face but he didn't connect to
anybody really in his life either so
it's a love story between these two gods
and as dark heroes they come together
and rescue each other in the end and
form the only real bomb they've ever had
in their life with each other and this
buddy relationship is comes out of their
darkness and their dark places and I
just wanted amp line something says he
said which is that I think part of the
reason NIC pizzolatto who's a genie
had it had a second season a true
detective that wasn't fabulous this last
one is he listened to his critics his
critics all said you know what Nick he
can't write women characters that has
just had woody and Matt that's all he
had so this season I think Nick listened
to that and he tried to write really
great female characters but he he lost
his focus and so the story was so dark
and all the guys died and they all died
tragically he had a real tragic ending
this season but I think it was because
he listened to and I think he'll tell
you this he listened to the critics that
were that were criticizing his vision of
the first season it's deadly to listen
to criticism at the wrong point it's
just deadly it never serves us well and
so when we are when we're when we're
thinking and cooking and loving our
story the last thing we want to hear is
a criticism of it it takes us away from
our story and I think you have to be
very careful about who you listen to
you